foreign
[Music]
African than Elizabeth Warren has Native
American and she wrote a Native American
cookbook called pow wow
idea how racist that is maybe like me
publishing so cooking with Stephen
crowded yes sir no [ __ ]
this fall
[Applause]
prepare
for not one
[Music]
but two Rebels with a cause now remember
Boy Scouts Boy how did that go awry
let's go with this single guy out into
the woods and he'll teach us to tie
knots
the rebels with a cause Comedy Tour
tickets on sale now at
ladderwithcrowder.com tour
listening
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
delicious am I am I okay Joe let's see
you you look good all right good yeah I
always I have a horrible tendency to
just come in looking like a slob and
Gerald's like just just fix fix your
collar you put a little effort into it
please put a little bit of effort into
it it's why I don't have a clothing
sponsorship but uh zenya
you're barking up the wrong tree
Adrian Brody doesn't know he doesn't
know what he's doing come on you can't
teach this uh glad to be with you look
let me issue a disclaimer before we get
to anything today I am going to be
discussing the Vatican okay
and why the Vatican right now is a
communist crapple now to be clear and
I've talked about this before this and
it relates to the Communist Chinese
party because the vatican's Cozy
relationship with them I love the
Chinese people which is why I hate the
Communist Chinese government I have a
lot of love for practicing Catholics
Bible believing Catholics of course who
exist throughout that's why I have a
problem with the political corruption in
the Vatican so just to be clear and if
you could do me if you're a Catholic and
you understand the difference hit that
like button it helps with the algorithm
but understand this is not targeted
towards practicing Catholics but the
people in the Vatican who have uh would
I say corrupt General malfeasance who've
been engaging in general malfeasance as
it relates to the communist government
of China
um we'll also be talking about why
libertarianism is dead because I know a
lot of you got mad when I discussed that
with Alex Jones and I don't apologize
for it all right
so that my question before I move
anything else are you worried about
Russia you worried about Russia hitting
the nuke button
I'm not
Luke yeah and uh by the way Dave Landau
is not here today he has a family
emergency to tend to so uh send your
prayers comment below prayers wish them
well but to him and I are going to be in
Nashville November 12th we added a
second show at 9 30 p.m a late show and
then Baltimore December 3rd the lyric
those are the only shows where there are
tickets left we're going to have to add
some here before the end of the year
Gerald a how are you sir I'm doing well
how are you I'm good sleep well I did
for the what I did really why how I
think it's because I my uh my daughter
is afraid of sleeping because she's had
a night she had a nightmare well you
showed her the terrifying clown movie I
know I shouldn't yeah that's that was a
bad idea I know she shouldn't know that
it floats down there and she uh she when
she starts falling asleep she like that
she wakes up afraid but then I think
kind of ensuing her I soothed myself
really I think so you read yourself
about that thank God that I did because
next episode I'm like I'm gonna shake
her
um so no I do think that joking in
singing lullabies to the kids like you
kind of because you don't do that for
you I never sing myself lullabies you
don't no but it soothes the Savage Beast
so we're not supposed to do that no I
know you don't so much sing lullabies as
talk dirty to yourself I've rocked
myself to sleep don't worry yeah let's
go with that so you good though I'm good
yeah all right great I know you've got a
lot of stuff that straight down Center
play here today is it oh I know as
someone who's a a student of the
theology I feel like this was a layup
for me but before we get to that we have
to uh watch something here really
quickly because Russia right now you
know Ukraine all of the
been a lot of stuff going on with them
and we're supposed to really care I
don't all that much I'm not going to lie
when it's one corrupt crap hole fighting
another corrupt crap hole the best you
can hope for is a double knockout okay
and I get that the citizens are caught
in the crossfire and your heart breaks
for them but I just don't think that we
should be involved in the irony is not
lost on me that I'm about to do a
segment on my libertarian you know
libertarianism doesn't work because I am
a non-interventionist as a general rule
I support Donald Trump when he said no
more was unless we take the oil well
yeah of course you take the resources
yeah you take their stuff so I don't
think we should be going to war to
helping anybody uh uh supporting a war
unless we get something out of the deal
but uh everyone's been talking about you
know Russia I do think the paper Tiger
has been exposed or we always thought
ooh the Russians yeah the Russians you
know they're the best in sport well we
sure it turns out they were walking
human pin cushions that's why they were
so great in sport yeah oh Russian
military okay sure but that's because
once upon a time they just threw bodies
at their opponents and now they don't
have as many bodies and all of their
artillery is out of date and they're not
nearly as the myth of the Russian
soldier has kind of been dying on the
vine here it's a bunch of drunken
conscripts so uh you may want to know
why they've stalled in their war with
Ukraine
I have some footage of a Russian short
this is an actual Russian soldier
training and you know what I think now
we can all call it a hunch
[Music]
ABAB down selected
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm [ __ ]
[Music]
I love how he's going the opposite
direction of his punches to kill any
momentum
the kicking babies yeah
I tell you what you should hide anyone
in the nursery yeah you said in the
midges after everything I will go into
preemie War don't show them who's boss
you're like oh are you here to hold the
babies I am here to kick the babies uh
vegetables by the way that could just be
a kid cosplaying I don't know if that's
an actual Russian soldier but I assume
so
based on what we've seen based on what
we've seen yeah Star Wars would win yes
give him a present you didn't tell me we
could have broomstick
I only have baby kick he has broomstick
this is not fair fight I'm gonna punch
and fold it
he's the only guy who might lose to
Stephen A Smith we can pull that if the
guys out there can pull that clip you
ever see him when he was hitting the
pads and he looked like he was punching
babies
criticizing UFC fighters yeah guys I'm
[ __ ] he's like I I was confusing cut
and then they show him he's like
punching downward like a little baby so
anyway here's the thing Russia they've
now been stepping towards you know full
mobilization and um there are some
lawmakers there pushing to reinstate the
draft also by the way we're talking
about the draft the reason that women
shouldn't have the vote
foreign
I love that ride because I want you to
be offended the women are talking you
think we don't no I don't think that
women should have the right to vote
unless you are eligible for the draft
and by the way it should apply
retroactively meaning that you get
drafted before any men since we were
drafted in Vietnam and you had the right
to vote you got the vote without the
mandatory draft which men had fairs Fair
they had to be eligible for the draft or
they couldn't vote it's very fair but
then again maybe we don't want all we
don't want the Army to be full of women
no offense because they're physically
weaker so don't want you to have 300 000
reservists have been called up in Russia
and here's the thing just last night
Vladimir Putin did make some uh threats
uh and if you watch this video I
actually had to double check to make
sure that it wasn't edited originally
all the references are available at
lottoscutter.com he was I wouldn't even
say these are veiled threats just
discussing nuclear options I should warn
that this has more to do with Ukraine
not launching a nuke in the States
because they wouldn't have the
capability like they're trying trying to
use a trebuchet if they tried to get it
over here so here let's watch them
foreign
right now go to CNN what is with the
faces of CNN what is with Bring It Up
full screen
it was Janet from the Muppets I think we
got a screen Grabber okay we'll grab a
screen grab all right sorry let's
continue the Vladimir Putin making empty
threats good breaking the Ukrainian War
breaking news because of a funny face on
CNN
all right all right yeah
I think he's going to die
guys
foreign
and Trump share anything in common as
far as policies but they do in the way
that they sort of try and Veil and couch
their bragging right we have a variety
of weapons and I am not going to that'd
be like that we have so many great
weapons I'm not going to say which words
but there are frankly a lot of weapons
the best weapons you'll find out oh I
hope I hope you know I hope you never
have to find out but maybe you'll find
out
push me and find out that's what he does
like we have weapons we don't want to
tell you what's like no you don't he's
like in some ways they're Superior to
Nato country in what ways
so many ways in so many ways they're so
much better than the NATO people who
frankly are not the best people they're
not sending their best
there is that similarity
but it keeps you on your toes there is
and I you know we'll see I think he uh I
think he could use a tactical nuke at
some point if he gets pushed too far I
hope not and it wouldn't be against us
like you said it'd be against Ukraine
yeah we'll see or maybe some kind of
maybe not necessarily a nuke but some
type of severe weapon I don't know their
biochemical capabilities or something
like a MOAB I have no idea exactly what
no one really knows what the
capabilities are we assumed that they
were far greater than they are and you
know what just remember this because
when everyone was saying for the longest
time that China was going to be the
world's greatest superpower you may not
know this that was almost like and you
would hear because now I think we all
agree right that the left is entrenched
with China
it was almost propaganda like Hitler
remember like give up you would all lose
your your soldiers your fellow soldiers
are dead right and it wasn't true that's
what they were doing with China saying
China's the next great superpower so we
better get in line Donald Trump was the
first president to Satan no I don't
think so and we saw the changes that
were made and right now we see this with
Russia where we all believe they were
the toughest sumbitches on the planet we
now know that's not true right what do
we not know about China
so don't lose hope right they've been
trying to tell you that well if China
gets in do we really know that there is
something there is a wild card when
you're dealing with a communist
government that oppresses its people
turns out a lot of people don't really
want to fight for them yeah they're
having the conscript soldiers and find
them or imprison them potentially in
Russia to get them to go and join this
right nobody really wants to do it as
opposed to here you know you just set up
a recruitment center at the local uh
drag queen Story Hour and your banks are
full done not effective but full we're
gonna do a segment on that tomorrow the
American Military that we're missing our
recruitment numbers and it's because the
exact kind of people who you want to be
in the military who used to go into the
military now are disgusted by it yeah
but we have a bunch of gender bending
whatever okay let's throw them at the
enemy you want to see Stephanie Smith
punching at babies yeah yes yes let's
see show Stephen A Smith punching it and
this is after by the way he CR he said
that Donald Cerrone quit
he said that he quit in the Octagon when
he just he had his nose broken and then
he in order to defend himself Stephen A
Smith released this video like I know
what I'm talking about what's
up
that would be too low to punch a dick
that's like thigh punching oh
there you go what I do right there is I
make them think I'm gonna hit them in
the face up I tap the thigh
guys Stephen A okay
is it Stephen A or Stephen A Smith well
Stephen A is a lot of times oh you're
going by the nomenclature okay you and
him are enough we're good friends you're
on a first name and initial basis first
Twitter hatred base
I've also got a weird face on CNN oh
okay all right
come on it's Janet from the Muppets man
let's bring that up later side by side
guarantee what's uncanny all right let's
go to another thing I don't know if this
is real or not and I didn't have time to
look it up I assume maybe uh so
you know what comment below if you or
anyone you know has been making uh the
uh the old soul food recipe of Nyquil
chicken because apparently enough people
have been doing it or there have been
enough trolls that the FDA has had to
release a statement saying that it's a
bad idea yeah so apparently there was a
tick tock Trend right now where people
are cooking if you want to call it that
they're chicken and
hence the names to turn raw chicken now
because this trend has taken over a ton
of headlines and been talked about for
all of your social media doctors are
warning people to not do this for
several reasons one you're likely taking
way more than the appropriate dose and
two if there's no point in the chicken
properly you could give yourself food
poisoning and three this one's the most
obvious to me it sounds completely
disgusting
yeah okay thank you I don't know I don't
mind the Cherry NyQuil it's not so bad
that's not so bad I could eat that I did
a shot of that in college and called it
my drinking because it's like two
percent alcohol or whatever I became
addicted to NyQuil almost but when I was
really sick and I was trying to get out
from when I lived in New York City and I
didn't realize this my my doctor told me
I said actually NyQuil was specifically
what's the doximally assassinate I think
it is it's not the same thing as
Benadryl
um which is diphenhydramine or something
like that but there's something in
specifically NyQuil and in the Unison
tabs that doximaline Sesame it's almost
like a dirty bomb so it affects all
these receptors so I took it for about a
week because I couldn't get out from
being sick and then after the week I was
like why am I why am I not able to sleep
and why am I getting cold sweats turns
out it was an NyQuil well the things you
choose to remember in your brain
well it was shocking I had to correct
you if it's going to be soul food
chicken using medicine it's going to be
Tussin chicken is it going to be testing
not going to be NyQuil I love how the
FDA they're so dumb like not only could
you accidentally be ingesting more yes
they're accidentally ingesting NyQuil
just like people are accidentally
putting cough medicine into Arizona
watermelon iced tea and mixing it with
Skittles it's an accident that's the
selling point how would this contribute
to people under cooking chicken they're
either going to cook it correctly or not
regardless of sauce
I don't know maybe neko's not as good of
a conductor I have no idea it protects
the chicken somehow so the FDA they
stepped in they warned boiling a
medication can make it much more
concentrated that's the point and change
its properties in other ways that'd be
like walking up to people who are
distilling you know who are making like
the honey oil from pot and be like no no
no no that's going to be too
concentrated like oh thanks we'll get
right on that [ __ ] like they don't care
what do you think why do you think
they're distilling it
put simply someone could take a
dangerously high amount of the cough and
cold medicine without even realizing it
thank you FDA yes
that's fantastic you're doing a bang-up
job yeah I don't I don't know why people
are just picking NyQuil you think you'd
be like you know what you have like
Robitussin salmon prednisone puffer fish
I don't know don't even get you high
does it I don't know I took it once and
I got amped I was like the Kool-Aid guy
by the way this is a live show Monday
through Thursday at 10 A.M Eastern if
you're not watching here on uh on Rumble
right now or mug Club that's where you
can go you might be watching on YouTube
and we appreciate it but we don't know
how long we'll be here right I just got
some notifications from Twitter this
morning I am in violation of German law
again yeah again nice
you're always in violation of Germany by
the way I think that that I think the
Robitussin thing started as just a let's
see if we can get people to not
Robitussin sorry NyQuil let's see if we
can get people to buy this and now the
FDA is coming on us like yeah you took
the bait again nobody's really doing
maybe some people are now I think people
are really doing it I think people are
doing it at the beginning maybe five
people are doing it well I was I was one
of the five
tried this recipe last night huh yeah
yeah it works wash it down with a little
Wild Turkey 101 was it in the Julia
Child cookbook yes today we will be
making NyQuil rotisserie they're sure in
the nick could do I like the way it
makes me feel in my near the regions
Swedish Chef just throwing it all over
them Nature's lubricant I always say
all right let's get to excess deaths in
Europe because I'm wishing that I was
one of them right now uh July and I need
to preface this we're going to cover
this tomorrow
yeah a little teaser uh excess deaths in
Europe now are up 16 in July 2022.
that's the highest of the year they sell
over 21 000 just in the UK alone excess
deaths and I we need to do more due
diligence okay
we'll cover this story tomorrow and I I
need to tread lightly correct I have one
primary concern
so we'll make sure that we cross our T's
and Dot our eyes yes and I will mostly
remain silent yeah what always happens
with this is this is what I would
encourage you to do if like I say if
nothing else from the show we make all
of our references publicly available you
can check the uh the description below
or go to loudoscatter.com is when you
see this you know right away that the
leftist artillery right the the the the
battle machine what the blood machine is
going to be in in full swing okay I was
trying to think battle regalia I'm like
that's the that's the difference
Battlestar Galactic beats Bears no you
know that they're going to come out and
write what the question you need to ask
yourself is okay what is the strongest
argument that the left is going to
present to try and either say this isn't
a concern or to try and say that it's
directly related to covet now
the lazy argument is they'll probably
say these are covered deaths the first
that's lazy it's not true you can look
at the numbers my guess is they will try
and say and this is sort of unfolding as
I send this we don't have all the
information I need to dive into the data
more deeply they'll try and say well
these are auxiliary deaths that still
are somehow related to Cove it's
something like long haul or while
completely missing the points due to
lockdowns people were unable to or
hospitals being overburdened they were
unable to see patients for other uh
significant Health Care issues it's like
do you hear yourself that's exact it's
all self-imposed so think come back
tomorrow but I want you to write down
and I mean this get a little notepad go
go analog write down what you think the
strongest arguments are that we will be
hearing as to why there are
an abnormal amount of excess deaths that
cannot be accounted for by covet alone
and then we'll dive in tomorrow
global warming yes wow the climates
change climate change yeah it's up to
we've updated that I love how in Texas
by the way remember they were like this
is this heat wave and then throughout
the rest of August and September it's
not the coldest August or September it's
been the most mild like the most
temperate yeah nothing like well is that
climate change because this is just
Pleasant dropping off well it's not even
dropping off it's just been consistent
like when was the last time here in
North Texas and if you're in Texas we
had 70 degree days yeah
consistently yeah we had we had a couple
of weeks of those yeah a couple of weeks
ago very rare at that time of year and
even now it's mostly low 90s or high 80s
in September it's often in the hundreds
we had a spike we're coming back down we
were at 97 yesterday so oh I'm just
saying we have tried to make sure the
audience gets the right info and you
don't I know but what I'm saying is I
remember when we moved to Texas and I
got heat stroke it was 110. exactly this
was uh well my family moved to Texas
what 18 years ago yeah well it's hotter
than Canada yes right
which is where breaking news which is
where your mistress lives
what his girlfriend's in Canada these
jokes don't work there you go come on
come on faces of CNN it's like a
prerequisite to work there it is weird
like I'd like to work at CNN here are my
credentials
do you have a weird face they must be
super smart you have the right stuff for
CNN weird-faced Karen I like the cut of
your jib face you'll be an executive at
no time
all right so uh let me get to something
here I saw people getting mad when I had
the Ash Wednesday with Alex Jones I'm a
recovering libertarian now if you look
at what I believe and you look at where
uh I would sort of line up on policies I
certainly would lean much closer to the
libertarian side of the spectrum but I
don't like using the word the reason for
it is when you have uh throughout time
like Greg Gutfeld Bill Maher Glenn Beck
and the reason magazine people all
claiming to be Libertarians what does it
mean and then when you watch the
libertarian debates it's just a bunch of
people with lisps arguing about weed and
cryptocurrency so I don't think there's
a whole lot there for me but I do
believe that originalist sort of
federalism conservatism certainly lines
up more with libertarianism
but we do find ourselves right now at a
point in this country where it can't
possibly function and let me explain to
you why this is before we get to the
Vatican story
libertarianism is a preventative measure
it works if you set it up from a
framework of small government and you
maintain it it is not a recovery it is
not a Curative measure and right now we
are at a point in this country where
preventative measure like libertarianism
can you can't fight something aggressive
meaning thousands of pages of new
legislation each day by saying well
there shouldn't be any I understand that
but there is and it almost never gets
taken off the books and the idea of free
markets which I support free enterprise
I support I've always said I'm not the
party of big business the party of small
business I'm the party of good business
the problem is there really are no free
markets in the biggest industries that
exist in the world today
and really when you look at one of the
few legitimate purviews of government it
is to protect us from threats both
external and internal and to ensure that
everyone is playing by the rules that
rules that might harm somebody yeah and
certainly now when you look at the
organizations we'll get into big Tech
big Banks Airlines health insurance
companies they are causing direct harm
to the American citizens and they are
doing so with carte blanche from our
federal government right well too big to
fail I mean you're supposed to have a
Level Playing Field so that people can
come in and compete and that's what
keeps goods and services more affordable
and gives everybody the opportunity to
innovate once you have these big
companies set up in the government
backing them up that's no longer the
case exactly so first do we have a we
don't have a stinger for question do we
oh all right so question
oh that's nice
let's what is libertarianism I didn't
know we had that sped no expense yes so
um what is libertarianism let's work
from this and since it's a slow news day
this is why we're going a little bit
macro and you know bear with me these
are things that that circulate in my
mind all the time and we don't always
necessarily get to hit it if we're under
the tyranny of today right this is a
framework that I think everybody needs
because I get a lot of messages and
especially when we do these live shows I
will be in Nashville and we'll just go
to a lot of cutter.com we get a lot of
people afterwards who come up and say
well as a small government conservative
you know what how do I sort of reconcile
that with the idea of needing to do
something with big Tech well it's it's
not hard the two are not at odds and
I'll explain to you why so first what is
libertarianism okay have a definition
here a political philosophy maintaining
that all persons are the absolute owners
of their own lives and should be free to
do whatever they wish with their persons
or property provided they allow others
the same Liberty there's nothing there
with which I disagree right to be clear
uh there's a moral psychologist I guess
this is title uh Jonathan had an
interesting hypothesis on sort of how
Libertarians think here's a clip there
is a big sex difference here men are
generally higher on systemizing women
are generally higher on empathizing and
what we find is that Libertarians are in
a sense the most masculine out there and
this is true even when we analyze only
the men separate all the men and women
just look at men libertarian men are the
highest on systemizing of any of the
three groups and they are the lowest on
empathizing same thing for women okay
now first off let me just say I I
disagree with that as it applies to
conservatism I understand the idea that
libertarianism is you know people might
be low on the empathy scale I will tell
you I am a conservative I'm a
constitutionalist I'm a federalist
because I am hyperly empathetic I look
at the people of Venezuela I look at the
people of you look at the people under
Stalin's regime you look at the people
under Castro you currently we're talking
about Venezuela uh I mean take your pick
China I look at them and I say it's
never possibly worked so you may see in
the short term saying well you don't
want to extend a hand no I see what
handouts lead to and because I don't
want to see the destruction of not only
Society but the human Spirit I'm a
conservative I think it's the most
empathetic worldview that you can
possibly have yeah absolutely it's the
only one that allows for compassion
because government is never
compassionate because it's they're
dealing with numbers that are too big to
be compassionate right dealing with one
you're dealing with thousands millions
of people and so you can't be
compassionate with that and that's why
you see uh leftist individuals they
donate far less to charity than
conservatives the single two biggest
determining factors I think it was a
Brooks wrote this a book called who
really cares if I'm not mistaken guys in
the edit Bay you can you can let me know
if that's right uh discuss who gave the
charity in the single biggest
determining factors were your faith
religion and uh your political
persuasion yeah and it was Christian it
was a huge difference because you have
Nancy Pelosi saying no the the
empathetic thing is uh is to have open
borders and to give all the money to
government and less than one percent to
charity and hey I go weed whack my lawn
that's how they
it's rules for thee and not for me right
well but it assuages their guilt right
there like oh I I can just you know pay
taxes and do this the government's
responsible for doing this the
charitable view is I'm responsible for
helping my local community so I'll give
to charity locally right and let these
guys go and do the work and I'll also
volunteer and not write off my underwear
Joseph Biden yeah remember when he did
that yes wrote off underwear I don't
know you could I didn't know you could
have write-offs first especially for his
underwear they're like eight thousand
dollars and Depends you're bullshitting
these are brown Hanes I think they only
made it's more of a cream taupe
slightly used
gently used that's on Amazon gently used
to new I almost blew a hole in them but
hey so uh yeah let's uh there was
something I was gonna say and now I just
lost my train of thought but it's okay
it doesn't matter this is this is one of
those days here let's go to this uh a
few examples
you are at a point now where the
libertarian argument can't apply when
you're talking about big Tech when
you're talking about these giant
non-government entities that have more
influence over the government and over
your life than even the government would
be justified inexcerning let me give you
a few examples okay Facebook
start with Facebook they are in arm
of left-wing government just to be clear
they don't allow any opinions that
contradict what what government agencies
or like the CDC or international
governing agencies like the who by the
way don't acknowledge taiwan's existence
hold on a second here is that political
is it political is this a private
industry or is it political if they are
taking marketing orders from the who
does not acknowledge taiwan's existence
Because by the way acknowledging
taiwan's existence might be the reason
for World War III I got that clip if you
want Oh of them not even acknowledging
that yeah let you know let's pull this
up it's bone
considered taiwan's membership
what
come again
she's cute hello
I can't hear you I couldn't hear your
question okay yeah let me let me let me
repeat the question okay let's move to
another one then right because because
I'm I'm actually curious on talking
about Taiwan as well on taiwan's case
here's the thing I should say that I'm
most upset because it's wrong I'm most
upset because I'm jealous that you can
just do that I was about to say you can
you can do that you could just end an
interview and it's like everybody's like
oh yeah sorry any argument in a
relationship like well why don't you
take out the trash
dude
can you I I didn't hear your question I
did this you can't see me yeah
doesn't make any sense at all so um you
know what the most fun part is about not
being able to post information that
can't contradict one of those I mean I
guess it's not fun but go it's when The
Who and the CDC don't agree then you
can't you can't be like hey the who said
because the cdc's like no we don't agree
or vice versa right like that's like
having an alcoholic father who beats
your mother who's also an alcoholic and
beats him back and it's just like
yeah whatever that's what happens in the
CEC and who fight so there you go that's
political and you're not allowed to
speak out against that now let me give
you more specific example Zuckerberg
also emailed Dr fauci personally in
March 2020 to collaborate with the NIH
to ensure quote people get authoritative
information from reliable sources uh not
to mention of course Facebook's decision
to ban the 45th president until at least
2023 for public safety concerns what is
a public safety concern we don't want
him to win
we don't want him to win really don't
want him to win so was this private
Enterprise is this free market when
people say go create your own Facebook
how do you do that how do you do that
when the head of Facebook's right meta
is directly emailing Dr fauci the
highest paid government official who's
never been elected think about that for
a second Dr fauci's never been elected
by you he's not even your representative
and he's talking with Zuckerberg to give
them marching orders who can control
what you say nothing about that is
emblematic of a constitutional republic
and nothing about nothing about that can
be solved to a preventative measure like
libertarianism it no longer applies here
by the way Facebook alphabet Apple
Amazon they've donated millions of
dollars to Joe Biden Democrats in 2020.
not to mention of course you have what
Zuckerberg and Twitter
and to set to a lesser degree Google
YouTube censored the hunter Biden laptop
story not only do they censor it they
censored the story while allowing
political opposition
to paint it as Russian propaganda right
and then said whoops we were wrong is
this a free market is this is the true
libertarian view well Facebook can do
whatever it wants well because when
you're saying Facebook can do whatever
it wants the libertarian in you is
saying Dr fauci Joe Biden Hunter Biden
Kamala Harris they can do whatever they
want you're not talking about a private
entity yeah well and it's funny because
Mark Zuckerberg he you know his solution
to say oh we're not as bad as Twitter
over there we didn't actually ban the
story and and make them you know go
silent for 10 days while their account
was banned we just Shadow banned it so
nobody knew right that we were making it
to where you didn't see it pop up in
your news feed and so it was a
significant reduction in the spread of
this information that potentially
according to polls not me could have
changed the outcome of an election it
absolutely would have changed outcome of
the election according to Biden voters
this bike it is banned so many times
according to Biden voters 12 of them I
believe him going by wrote said we would
have it would have changed my vote if I
knew about the hunter buying laptops
right that switches all of the Swing
States yeah and how does libertarianism
fix that yeah let's go on to another
example so now I have the biggest
organizations the biggest companies that
have ever existed throughout the history
of mankind the west west Indian Trading
Company I think employed like a fifth of
population Earth do not as powerful
as the big tech companies uh and by the
way they all email each other do you
think they accidentally all banned Alex
Jones and Donald Trump within 24 hours
of each other right it's not a
conspiracy if it only requires five
people to make it happen so let's go to
example number two Banks hey Banks I
agree with you I agree with you that
Banks should have the right to do what
banks want to do they should be but
banks are not separate from the
government if you look at Banks and you
look at hedge funds they manipulate the
economy for example to short stocks
before we even get into the balance
remember Robin Hood remember they
stopped the purchasing of GameStop stock
for just because redditors were boosting
it now you might not like what redditors
were doing you might not but guess what
that was a free market was a bunch of
people who came together and then the
bank said well hold on a second this is
this is uh this is too powerful so we
need to make sure that someone steps in
uh from Regulatory Affairs to stop you
from playing the game that we have
already rigged and they sided with Wall
Street they sided with a hedge fund and
several hedge funds really that were
shorting GameStop and driving the price
down and basically people said that's
not fair we don't like that and Robin
Hood steps in and says doesn't matter if
you like it or not right we're going to
put a halt to this so nobody can sell
their stock or buy whatever the the
parameters were you just can't trade
this stock anymore it's like for no
reason other than somebody was losing
billions of dollars that they liked yeah
so we didn't stop it you just can't
trade it what else would I do with
stocking it's just sitting there hey
also when it comes to charitable giving
um the characteristic most likely to
increase giving was marriage but then
also Republicans do donate more than
Democrats and also religious practices
the behaviorable behavioral variable
most consistent with generous giving is
that from uh David Brooks's book
um this is from a few different sources
okay because he wrote a whole book on it
I think called who really cares uh I
think it was I think it was David Brooks
there's so many Brooks so um there's a
Shawshank Brooks uh not for long so you
have these Banks okay so you have big
Tech now you're happy enough for lunch
to be tangling that'll be me at the end
of this show yeah
[Laughter]
don't worry I'll leave a sardine can
with a couple couple of bucks buried
underneath an oak tree yeah she really
saved him there so
by the way donut overwhelmingly to
Democrats the myth of the big Bank the
Fat Cat Wall Street Banker right
Republican that's it couldn't be no
further from the truth certainly in the
modern era maybe once upon a time not
anymore so let's look at hedge fund
managers you have Sussman Snyder uh
Eichner donated 70 million each to
Democrats from 2008 to the 2018 midterms
2020 Wall Street backed Biden to Trump
74 million to 18 million uh Biden has
had multiple AIDS uh ties to Blackrock
venture capital from firm Revolution a
consulting firm Precision strategies
these are the biggest companies that
exist in the world right too big to fail
and the current Secretary of State
Anthony blinken founded the Consulting
from West exec which is um or I guess I
should say they formally employed also
gen saki CIA deputy director David Cohen
director of the National Intelligence
Avril Haynes so another it's this Unholy
Alliance of [ __ ] heels across the board
you have people who have worked in these
companies hedge funds right who give
overwhelmingly the Democrats who have
worked with these Banks then they get a
point pointed to unelected roles in
government and sometimes that even
involves roles
in your intelligence committees the CIA
the FBI think about that for a second
think of the path from working for a
company that gives 74 million dollars to
a politician and follow that little
Trail right like follow the [ __ ]
Trail back of a kid's placement and you
end up say deputy director yeah
absolutely well the most surprising stat
that you said in there was that Wall
Street backed Biden to Trump and the
number was 74 to 18.
the economy was booming under Donald
Trump if anything they should have been
like we're rolling in the dough that
Trump has basically got like the Dows at
thirty thousand dollars at three he's
got these like placards thrown in the
bathroom because he doesn't have room
for him anymore for the records he was
setting and they're backing they're just
you know what explanation for that other
than
they want special treatment well not
only special treatment I can tell you
why the market goes up right the market
overall has been going up under Biden if
you look at it overall as a whole you
have bad days uh and you can argue about
the rate of climb but the government
wins out over sorry the the market wins
out over time no you said it right the
first yeah the government but the market
wins out over time the problem is with
Donald Trump unlike with Joe Biden look
is anyone buying this [ __ ] when they say
the economies but you know it's not I
know it's not they tried to say keep in
mind under Jimmy Carter and under Barack
Obama they tried to Gaslight you and say
no no the economy is great everyone knew
that it wasn't the case you would even
have the biggest attractors of Donald
Trump saying well what's the economy
worth when you have someone who brings
shame to us on an international stage
the reason why the market wins out the
banks will do fine no matter what it's
that the average American was doing
better yeah the banks could be doing
better if the average Americans were
doing slightly worse the banks could be
even though they're making tons of money
hand over fists billions of dollars
going to these CEOs who by the way are
glorified managers they're not actual
business owners they say but we can make
more billions if we create a permanent
class of renters
we could make more billions if the
average salary under Donald Trump the
average sale went up like five thousand
dollars I think under Barack Obama the
first was it eight years it was thirteen
hundred three years of Donald Trump was
five thousand dollars the average
American benefited and the banks and
Wall Street benefited also right now
Wall Street banks are beneficiaries at
your expense that's the big difference
but here's the thing greed cannot harm
you from Big Banks if they don't receive
bailouts if they don't get preferential
treatment the less red tape there is
the harder it is for them to get ahead
why do you think these giant
corporations always support big
government policies because it
eliminates the mom and pop competition
again
is your libertarianism how is it going
to solve this here and if your answer is
go in and just slash it's not going to
happen that's not what that's not what
happens with our legislative process how
do you fix it libertarianism right now
it's a preventative measure that cannot
offer Solutions so
let's we've do you have anything else to
add we have okay we have big Tech we
have Banks all right now we can go on to
other corporations being an army group
these are sort of what we might say
miscellaneous uh yeah special interest
groups um like Planned Parenthood 45
million to back Democrats in the 2020
election
and it explains why in 2019 all but
three Democrats voted against the born
alive survivors protection act and
that's one of the few bills that is
aptly named just to be clear yes yes it
means what it says like the green New
Deal like what is that I don't know what
that means well that's by Design the
born alive abortion survivors protection
act here I want you to picture what it
actually yes
[Laughter]
yes babies were being born alive and
they're being allowed to die wasn't
happening in huge numbers but it was
enough if it was more than zero and uh
Democrats voted against it hmm
I wonder why all of them all except for
three with a conscience now we go on to
Visa Mastercard American Express who by
the way have received billions of
dollars in bailout money they're now all
going to track gun purchases using a new
purchase code which by the way could be
provided to the government considering
that private data has been given over to
the government by these companies in the
past let's look at Airlines one of your
favorite one of your favorite businesses
I'm sure they're beholding the
government after receiving over 54
billion dollars in bailouts and I think
that's even just the most recent round
with covid-19 relief hey hold on a
second now that we're back in full swing
has has that been passed on to you let's
think about Libertarians right the free
market do you get a bag of peanuts
what about the check what about the
check baggage fee is is your airline
experience now more pleasant or at least
as pleasant as it was pre-covered or
does it still suck because once the
government steps in and says all right
we're gonna give you this money it comes
with strings attached guess what it
never gets better it only gets worse
so let me recap this for you and I'd
like to you know comment below if you
disagree I have a lot of libertarian
friends and I agree with the principles
of it I'm just saying that pragmatically
it doesn't apply here what do we have we
have collusion between
big Tech and what do I mean the most
powerful companies that ever existed
you've got Facebook you've got sorry
meta
whatever like we don't know what that
means so you've got meta Twitter YouTube
uh Google Amazon apple right okay we
have collusion between them all the
banks all the big credit card companies
multiple corporations and special
interest groups Airlines
where do you you're a citizen
where do you go
if you want to live in a free market
well just don't be anywhere on big Tech
go create your own
well you know just uh don't do any
banking with big go create your own well
just don't use any of the major credit
card companies just use cryptocurrency
yeah that'll never be regulated if it
becomes as powerful as fiat currency
Airlines go buy a plane the point is
we're at a point where it's not
something that you can simply solve
through free market Alternatives because
they've been locked down and that can
only happen through the corruption that
has taken place between the government
and these corporations and I get it the
irony is not lost on me that we do need
some fighters in government to try and
roll this back because it cannot simply
be solved through the free market at
this point it doesn't exist yeah
when you basically handicapped the
entire system you can't just say oh well
the system will correct itself no you're
the ones running the system right and
it's never worked in history before so
well this segment is terrible it's Times
Like These I'm confused how any of these
guys have a woman I know these morons
have nothing to offer a lady well I
wouldn't say nothing oh why is that
landlord well at least after being with
them they'll make a happy Widow
especially Gerald
check the benefit s are you on your all
right I don't know why we installed I
don't know we installed up the balcony
and gave them season tickets
okay that was really mean Gerald it's
not true well why don't you cry about it
it's not true some people they just hate
for no reason Jill yeah okay what I tell
myself so now we'll move on to now that
we've offended Libertarians and Russian
soldiers
there's one Russian soldier watching
like watching through VPN he's like hey
I used to be a fan
I can't I'm using Starling for Elon Musk
from ukrainians no longer I get people
sometimes remember like I used to be a
fan until you and then they talk about
how I offended them on their thing yeah
like I used to be a fan until you said
women weren't funny well today you've
clearly proven me wrong so
Let's uh
move on to hit the like button if you
think the women in general aren't funny
now it doesn't mean they can't be funny
they just don't have to be funny and so
they largely aren't now
[Music]
let's move on to the Vatican again to be
clear I need to reiterate this again
because sometimes you'll get Catholics
you'll get very this is just like when I
talk about the Communist Chinese
government when I say I cannot stand the
Chinese I mean the government not the
people
same thing I'm here I'm talking about
the Vatican not even just the pope I'm
talking about the Vatican okay not
bible-believing Catholic Bible believing
Catholics who I think want better
from the people uh who are their
International Representatives if you're
cath I would love to hear from you in
the comments I genuinely would because
uh I have some friends who are Catholic
actually this segment I worked with one
of our researchers who is Catholic who's
absolutely livid about the situation
yeah so many are and I know we're going
to hear from them yes one way or the
other we're gonna hear it so here's
what's been going on the uh the Vatican
the pope
um they've basically
abandoned this Hong Kong Cardinal yeah
and I need to sort of get into the ins
and outs here it's a little bit nerdy
all the references are available at
lotto's credit.com where they have uh
signed a deal they've signed a deal with
the Devil and what they have done with
China
the Vatican so let me set this up in
Hong Kong you have a cardinal Joseph sen
he's on trial for why assisting
pro-democracy protesters during the 2019
demonstrations you would think this is a
good thing here's a clip after the Hong
Kong national security law was passed
the Cardinal was arrested in May for his
role as a trustee in a relief fund known
to help pro-democracy protesters who
participated in the 2019 demonstrations
in Hong Kong Cardinal Zen is well known
for his outspoken calls for change in
China as all believers we must be Justin
Bieber fan does it mean that we can hope
in immediate success
because every relation
depends on two parts and now if China
doesn't change
its policy there's nothing we can expect
all six of the defendants including
Cardinal Zen have pleaded not guilty the
trial is set to last until September
23rd and if found guilty the Cardinal
could face serious fines or jail time
yeah yeah I'm sure he's going to face
fines or jail time he's going to face
disappearance time yeah exactly and just
to be clear before because I I get it
and Catholics it's not lost on me that
you've been the whipping post for a lot
of the media and the entertainment I
understand it I get why you're touchy
but just see where we're coming from I'm
saying that guy
brass balls fat guy's a cardinal yeah
where's the cat where's the Cavalry
coming over the hill for that guy
because I think that guy actually has
something to lose and not the guys in
the red stupid shoes they deserve the
support if we're talking about
Christianity and let's use the term
Catholic Christianity interchangeably I
understand the nominational difference
here if we're talking about spreading
the gospel throughout the world the
Catholic church and the Vatican should
make it their rezone that to help that
man who has a brass pair of balls I'm
supporting him which is why I am furious
with the Vatican and this Pope and if
you're honest with yourself you are too
so this guy's accused of setting up an
illegal fund to pay the legal costs of
those uh arrested not like Kamala Harris
who you know the rioters who burn down
Walgreens I don't think this guy burned
down uh no no no no Believers don't do
that so he's being prosecuted under the
same law used to Target the Triad yeah
exactly which is super strange right so
racketeering was a charge that they
brought up so that they could take care
of gangsters and Mobsters so that
basically this is like charging the
Archbishop of LA with racketeering even
though he did no racketeering yeah right
so the Cardinal Capone they're making up
laws they're like oh well this worked
for gangs I mean he set up a defense
fund and he wears a funny kind of hat so
yeah let's put him in there yep that's
exactly like what it is and by the way
the Poke Vatican nowhere to be found no
not a peep
how is that not infuriating
to every single Catholic out there
across we've called men to the mat we
call non-denominational Christians than
that on Prosperity Gospel tons of
pastors we've called tons of pets
pastors to the mat we're all the
Catholics
certainly wear those with the giant
rooms full of gold so when Zen was
arrested this was all the Vatican said
non-committally I might add but that's
just that's that's me you and yeah
that's me I'm editorializing
but you'll see why
the Holy See has learned with concern
the news of cardinal Zen's arrest and is
following the development of the
situation with extreme attention oh good
to break good to break your gauge from
the 12 year old boy
that's the only one that's the only one
I'll do
maybe two more so I have a question for
you right here I like that
why is the Vatican this is the why are
they silent this should be like catnip
yeah for the Vatican hey you have a
cardinal who's out there doing the
Lord's work who's pro-democracy right
you guys have taught you guys that the
pope support of black lives matter hey
this guy is actually facing persecution
and I don't mean that in the way that
people say about you know South
Americans just fleeing shitty socialist
governments that's not actual
persecution this guy could be
accidentally disappeared for what he's
doing this should be a layup for the
Vatican to say we stand with our own we
stand with those who are spreading the
gospel
so
I'm asking you why I think I have an
answer
yeah pretty good answer leading leading
the witness so in 2018 the Vatican
signed a very shady agreement again
editorializing with Beijing
and it had some Provisions including
that the Vatican recognized Seven
Chinese Bishops appointed without the
vatican's approval
that the Vatican can only pick bishops
from a pool selected by the communist
Chinese party and by the way that's up
for renewal in October this this
agreement is disagreement yeah
and here's something else just to be
clear
um
in China Hong Kong you may not know this
only a communist Chinese party version
of the Bible is even allowed right
that's been Rewritten it's a crime
to have a Bible that isn't approved and
it has it's been Rewritten there are a
lot of parts that have been changed and
by the way I don't it's a really weird
ad in there in Revelation where it says
and behold a mouth on a horse yeah I
don't think that was in there it's just
it's yeah what's the red horse Behold a
yellow horse yeah
[Laughter]
I have no idea my point look take it up
with the Communist Chinese paper my
point is this
the Vatican is signing a deal with the
country
that doesn't even allow its citizens to
have the Bible yeah hey how about this I
would be and I'm going to use some
profanity here my stance would be if I'm
the international representing uh
governing body of Christianity
[ __ ] Hue communist Chinese party you
don't get to appoint vaticans and why
would you trust you to do that anyway
you rewrote the Bible and you arrest
people if they have the real one right
why is the Vatican playing ball with
this country it's the same reason
they're silent when actual Cardinals
doing the real work that true Catholics
believe in
are persecuted right and weren't they I
mean the whole point of this aren't we
supposed to stand up for those who are
oppressed right now aren't we supposed
to like try and take the gospel to the
world and try to to heal the
brokenhearted right and try to to bring
Comfort to those who are suffering and
to shine a light on some of the worst
atrocities happening on our planet right
now and say that love and compassion is
the way to go not you know jailing your
citizens because they're uyghurs and
putting them in work camps yeah isn't
that like the like if you don't have
that as your mission like if you didn't
get the the gospel and so that Jesus
said go out and tell the world like if
you're missing that what are you doing
here you're just raising some funds and
living in a place that's pretty well
protected and getting to ride around in
a pretty sweet golf cart and wear red
shoes that are cobbled together for you
personally there's a guy who makes those
red shoes that's what I'm saying they're
cobbled together personally like I get
it but this is this she gets fired is
that his resume red Shoemaker formerly
you made shoes I made red shoes just red
shoes for how many people you made red
clothing no I made red shoes only yes
for one guy poppy batons yes
my Louie peas so
um Let's uh go this is by the way
according to the persecution Watchdog uh
voice of Martyrs uh the Communist
Chinese party announced plans to update
the Bible to quote keep Pace with the
times update the revisions will include
adding core socialist values and
removing passages that do not reflect
communist beliefs no so it basically
turns it into a pop-out book yes
headline also says calling Jesus a
sinner yes so he called he called Jesus
a sinner it's really this is actually
hilarious in the Communist Chinese Bible
in the Communist Chinese Bible you know
the part where there's a woman who has
sinned and I think she's been caught in
the act of adultery and Jesus is like he
who is without sin cast the first time
so Lane brought this to me uh gingersnap
and he was like yeah they called Jesus a
sinner here and I'm like you kind of
buried the lead it wasn't just that they
called him a sinner it's that everybody
walked away in the story and Jesus
chooses in the Bible not to condemn this
person too and says if they've all left
I will not condemn you as well so the
the updated version is
Jesus then took up stones and stoned her
himself and said ah but I'm a sinner too
Jesus is like everybody else left so
I'll do the job lady here we go so it's
poorly written communism it is poorly
written like Jesus was so dumb that he
started like he started stoning Soraya
Amos like oh no I forget I'm a bad man
yeah I forget I'm a sinner too oh no you
I mean how does that even Jesus would
know right he would yes so it was like
yes Jesus is Jesus being a sinner that's
you know that's a line you can't cross
Hey where's the Vatican speaking out
against this I know where's the Vatican
on why would you I understand you have
to compromise but sometimes to have to
make political deals for example
but oh that again you want to sign an
agreement with Beijing when their
Express policy is that Jesus is the
exact opposite of who we all believe
Catholic Baptist Lutheran came to be
which is the Spotless lamb no for
atheists out there if it doesn't matter
if you disagree you do understand the
corruption right you do see it right
yeah that is burying the lead yeah I
wasn't going to read the whole communist
Chinese Bible he said that to me and I
just started dying laughing in here I
was like you got to be kidding me they
also by the way they also bailed the the
band the sale of the online Bibles so
you can get them you can get them
without a permit at gun shows ah
loophole
[Music]
Cardinal Zen uh was a Critic of the
Vatican hmm he was a Critic specifically
of their deal with China when it was
signed and he said they're sending the
flock into the mouths of wolves it's an
incredible betrayal look don't miss the
point cat I get I get emails anytime I
say I'm not saying all Catholics I'm
saying good Catholic Cardinal Zen
bad Catholics the whole Vatican
the whole Vatican if there is not one
moral man that whole place should be
turned into a pillar of salt at this
point this is one of their own who needs
them and by the way needs all of us to
raise awareness sure I disagree with
some Theology and Catholicism but
generally speaking I think that we're
within state borders of each other and I
certainly don't want to see Cardinal Zen
put effectively in a gulag because the
people who sent him out there hung him
out to dry or are you about to say that
so Biden is addressing the United
Nations and specifically after Putin
starts to do I'm going to cut to that
for a minute and see or do we want to
keep going and see if they break in with
anything interesting you know what you
guys let me know what's going on we'll
go I wanna I I want to defend this
Cardinal here because he needs our
defense because he's very slight this
guy might poop himself and if he does
we'll break to that I guarantee he's
already pooped himself and he's going to
write it off so China's infiltrated the
obviously they've infiltrated members of
our government they've infiltrated you
know um Joe Eric swalwell's sex closet
and now the Vatican
the most powerful religious institution
in the world and this really does fit a
pattern just to be clear with the
Vatican uh and I have a real problem
with them I have a real problem with the
Vatican not Catholics the Vatican I keep
feel like I keep having to restate it
just hit like if you understand that
because I don't want to have to deal
with something like well you said this
no look Zen and I are cool
okay and he's Catholic so let's go back
to then okay just to see the
inconsistencies and the hypocrisy is
very similar to what was it something uh
Pharisees sad juicy something like that
I thought Jesus had a problem with them
not drawing parallels between them and
the Vatican they're certainly not Pious
so 2019 Pope Francis uh
chastised uh Trump of course for wanting
to build a wall and he said Builders of
walls be they made of razor wire or
bricks will end up becoming prisoners of
the walls they build migrants should be
accepted protected and integrated and if
a country cannot handle the numbers the
migrants should be distributed among
other countries well that sounds really
Noble from a guy with multi-million
dollar red shoes uh let's go to now what
exactly does it take to become a citizen
of the Vatican well citizenship is only
granted to those who quote reside in the
Vatican because of their worker office
those who wish to move to the Vatican
must have their citizenship approved by
the pope or the papal Authority oh and
uh by the way for well we're reminded
about them talking about walls this is
the actual Vatican ah those look like
big walls that have been there a long
time yeah that's not a screenshot from
Apocalypto yeah the Vatican yes so rules
for thee not for me you can't have walls
why so that you can keep all of them yes
exactly because we already have a wall
it's easy easy for us to say walls are
bad right well then tear yours down
Vatican let's let's live by what we
preach right and by the way they don't
need walls that big but no no you see
those you see those Cardinals and
they're not going to be scaling walls
like that that's not gonna happen a few
hundreds with a grappling hook they can
get right in no besides in angels and
demons I think there were so many secret
passages that got in any way also uh Tom
Hanks mullet the shoes are climbing
shoes yes
clogs climbing clogs they're cleats
all right so again we're going through
the history of the vaticans that you
understand why it's not too out of their
pattern historically in throwing someone
under the bus and feeding them to the
Communist Chinese party let's go back to
then
you may not know this all references
available at a lot of credit.com World
War II
Vatican by the way they're higher they
had a an aggressively neutral let me put
it that way stance towards the Nazis
and uh uh yeah the Pope Pius so what was
his number Popeyes was it 12th I believe
it was the 12th yeah I don't know so
many numbers many of them yes he was
notoriously silent obviously during the
Holocaust according to one Nazi
Ambassador over one thousand Jews were
rounded up and taken away under the
Pope's very windows and we all know
about them sort of transporting uh some
of the Nazis out and I look I understand
that there's a gray area where some
Nazis were forced to be Nazis but if you
actually look at the reading that came
the writing that came from the Vatican
that's not all they were doing well and
so in this story under the walls that
under the windows that actually comes
from when they were rounding up Jews
they fled to the Vatican for protection
oh that was a mistake and we're
basically pinned up against the walls
and taken basically they had nowhere to
go right so that's why he says we
rounded them up and took them away under
the Pope's very Windows they were
watching us do this see I thought it was
figurative Windows nope this was
literally what happened oh boy now maybe
the not alleged Oracle on the other side
of the compound and he couldn't
technically it couldn't have been the
Pope's window anyway what's going on
yeah and they didn't take a stand no oh
almost exactly like right now with this
Cardinal who could be locked away
forever surprising for supporting
democracy something I thought because
you condemned the United States for not
apparently supporting black which wasn't
really democracy it was just mob Rule
and burning [ __ ] down correct I think
it's a pretty clear example again how do
these people support someone with
something to lose that's a really
important indicator of someone's
character what do they do when they
stand to lose everything this Cardinal's
end
you know where he stands
you know what kind of character you know
you know the stuff he's made of
we also have an answer and people from
the Vatican
because there's something to lose so
that was then Nazis now you have more
recently Pope Francis advocated what for
the disarmament of Americans right after
Uvalde
Pope Francis said it is time to say
enough to the indiscriminate trafficking
of children sorry arms you said arms
Freudian slip how about we'll just
Shuffle the guns from store to store
for a few decades Pope Francis
not a peep
that was the last one
where the hell do you get off telling us
that telling us what we have to do with
our Firearms you don't have any
constitutional rights the vacuum you
don't you don't recognize them and by
the way you don't even recognize basic
human rights as seen by the Cardinal you
guys throw under the bus and I'm not
even sure he's read the part of the
Bible where Jesus says you guys are
gonna need swords he's like God we have
two okay that's that's that should be
good yeah like I understand there's a
lot of go a lot of meaning in that and a
lot going on but Jesus was not for just
taking a beating right it wasn't for not
protecting yourself right there were
certain times where it was fine to do
that yeah hey do you know why we need to
have our Firearms Pope Francis I know
and I know we're all supposed to Iran
fallible and what have you
um the reason that we need arms is so
that we aren't turned into an entire
nation of cardinals ends the guy who
used to run to the bus that's why
so the government can't come in and
treat us like Cardinals and just to be
clear all the Liberals here in the
United States do you understand like
would you say he's an extremist because
I know you want to say that anyone here
who wants to go to a gun show or anyone
here who wants to live out in a rural
area or anyone here who has a problem
with the CIA or believes in disarming or
sorry disbanding the FBI as an
extremists is that an extremist because
Zen is a perfect example of someone
who's defenseless
that's why we need him Pope Francis
hey you know what if you if you need a
couple of history books as to why we do
it here and by the way also why the
founders want to talk about the signers
of the Declaration of Independence they
were leery of back then militant
Catholics signing why because they felt
that they might have a higher allegiance
to the Vatican and it wasn't because of
the Catholic faith it was because of the
political power that existed within the
Vatican and they said we cannot have
signers who have an allegiance to some
other government entity Beyond this
Constitution of the United States that's
that's a historical fact and we see now
why yeah are you protected by the way is
the Swiss guard armed the people that
protect you are they armed oh yeah so
you do believe in having guns for
protection just not not for other people
they only believe in really large walls
so uh then you have a cardinal uh uh
cubic I believe is his name an
Archbishop of Chicago said the Second
Amendment did not come down from Sinai
the right to bear arms will never be
more important than human life well okay
I get that you're a cardinal you're a
stupid man
the whole reason for firearms
is to protect human life as a matter of
fact it's the only reason it's the only
reason some people misuse the tool to
take human lives just like if you don't
know how to use a tool and you decide to
try and use a wrench instead of a hammer
yeah I did that once it was embarrassing
you know what else didn't come down from
Sinai you're talking about the Ten
Commandments sir most of what Jesus said
of course he expounded upon the Ten
Commandments but he said a lot of other
stuff too so if you're saying well it
didn't come down from Sinai so it must
be you know something that we need to
discard you're throwing out most of what
Jesus said no but they have a different
they have a different version where
Moses came down and said I bring you
these Lord's Ten Commandments and these
really cool red shoes
and it would be for the man yeah he was
wearing two golden calves yeah well
they were having quite the party when
yeah they weren't quite kind of pissed
that was actually the second draft he
was like all right we need to change
some of these rules these guys are going
crazy yeah you guys are a little bit
nuts no think about this oh is that the
center it comes down from Sinai what
about the Vatican what about all the
stuff that you guys do all these rituals
and I understand that because my I
understand the point that not every
single rule or certainly Spirit of the
law that we follow comes from Sinai but
you're a stupid person can we say this
the pope is a stupid person a lot of
these Bishops are stupid people these
Cardinals a lot of them not all are
stupid people if you don't understand
that Firearms are necessary to
protecting human life oh wait a second
you do because I've heard your dumbass
statements on Ukraine and Russia
you know it is because you've asked that
we help Ukraine how are we helping them
guns
guns the answer is when you are fighting
evil with guns the answer is always guns
folks it's all guns these days kids
so let me recap and then we'll go to
Biden [ __ ] his pants here live the
Vatican is what silent on the
persecution in Hong Kong of a cardinal
who they should be standing by they
signed a shady agreement with Beijing
that's why they're silent on China
Banning the Bible and claiming that
Jesus is a sinner which kind of a big
deal you would think in the Christian
faith immigration for uh for for thee
but not for me and uh you know what they
probably uh maybe helped out a little
bit in the Holocaust or at least didn't
take the kind of stand that you should
you know what you should have done if
they were not saying something because
they're like oh we'll be destroyed or oh
maybe we'll you know Catholics be killed
fine that is the price you pay look at
what the leader did look at what the
leader of our faith did he laid down his
life for everybody in the flock if it
costs you everything if you absolutely
disappear from the map you have to trust
that God has a plan and his church will
carry on not if you think you're the
only church not if you think that the
building that you reside in the Vatican
the artifacts everything that you have
is what makes faith faith it isn't I'm
sorry I understand the importance of it
but in that moment you stand up and you
say that's wrong yeah and if it costs us
everything it's still wrong we'll go to
heaven knowing we have a clear
conscience and we did the right thing
but that's not what happened and let's
say that you even believe that this Pope
is only infallible on issues of
spirituality and speaking ex-cathedral
because that came from Sinai St Peter's
chair there was a Sinai thing that's
true
let's say you believe all of that okay
even if you do when there's a cardinal
who's looking at imprisonment and let's
be honest likely death or severe torture
in China for speaking up for Christian
values and you aren't saying anything
you're still you're still a Chinese
finger puppet
let's see what Joe Biden has to say
right now in front of the stuff a lot of
people in front of the late 80s Thriller
marble wall that's true they have it not
updated this Sharon Stone going to come
out and cross her legs let's see
this is the human cost of climate change
and it's growing not lessening oh great
so as I announced last year nice gold
wall unit our Global responsibility
my Administration is working with our
Congress to deliver more than 11 billion
dollars a year to International climate
Finance
telephone
this is a perfect example people say we
need to find Common Ground we're all
hearing the same thing and right now
he's going I did 11 billion dollars in
climate finance and we're going 11
billion dollars in climate Finance
[ __ ] uh let's continue vulnerable
countries adopt
to the impacts of climate change and
build resilience move yeah
this sorry is enormous
so let this be the moment
we find within ourselves
the will to turn back the tide of
climate Devastation looking at you
Devastation what's Devastation
sustainable clean energy economy to
preserve our planet yeah it's working
like a it's working like a charm in
California people are using gas
generators to Electric electrically
charge their Teslas just to be clear and
it's it's working like a charm by the
way in uh in Germany and these places in
Europe have said you know what we better
start up uh we better start up looking
at nuclear hey even Elon Musk the guy
who's done more to spearhead Green
Technology here you know we're really
talking about electric cars that you
can't do it unless you start using
nuclear and I don't know if you know
this do you know how many carbon
emissions come from a nuclear pump do
you have a take a guess take a guess
uh
a lot zero oh I was zero zero and the
lowest deaths per kilowatt hour I
believe of any energy uh resource
certainly lower than solar than wind or
coal I know that
but I but we have Three Mile Island once
in Fukushima and Chernobyl so we don't
do it if you want to it's about this and
if you look at the green policy that
he's talking about it's a Monumental
shift from the middle class to a few
select companies yeah let's see what
else he has to say resulting one of the
largest global Health fundraisers ever
held in all history all you ever talk
about is also taking spending money
and putting put Destiny 93
people around the world experience acute
acute food insecurity I thought you were
saying how Hunter Biden refers to his
niece today I'm announcing another 2.9
billion dollars oh good more of our
money U.S support
for life-saving humanitarian and food
security assistance can you fix the
problem please all we're doing is
throwing money at the symptoms and not
fixing the cause of the problem and it's
like hey this year we're going to give
more money to this and more people than
ever are hungry hey let me ask you this
let me ask you this we all know right
can we all agree can we all agree that
of course we're not going to be
completely transitioned for example to
electric vehicles uh by I think they're
saying it the earliest they can hope for
is 20 30 something yeah okay we're
talking about creating all this new
infrastructure and superchargers that by
the way cannot be supported by the
current power grid and you've seen me I
changed my mind on Tesla's not because I
think they're more green they're
actually less green I just think they're
cool they're pretty fun to drive but I
don't care I don't care how many
seagulls have to die in an oil spill I
want to go plaid now
um
all this electron electric car
infrastructure
the last time we reinforced our our gas
infrastructure
we're talking about lineups are on the
gas station right when was the last time
we made that more efficient because
efficiency will always lead to
incremental gains right to to lead to
cleaner energy to cleaner uses of that
energy we're talking about developing
infrastructure by the way for cars that
most people don't want can't afford or
are impractical we're nowhere near
electric cars being practical for the
vast majority of this country they're
very fun to drive yeah need to do a road
trip drive across the country we're not
there yet live in an apartment where you
don't have your own charger we're not
there yet I know that you have solutions
that are all far off but we're not there
yet but what are we doing to improve the
infrastructure of the energy that we
need to use now well guess what that
would help you the average American not
the big companies with these no big
government contracts
they're the best cars powered by coal on
the planet yeah exactly even Elon Musk
has said so yes of course transition
let's watch more of this guy in front of
his marble slabs scaling up innovative
ways to get drought and heat resistance
of farmers who need them
while Distributing fertilizer and
improving fertilizer efficiency that
farmers can grow more hey why was there
a shortage why was there a fertilizer
shortage oh that's right you created a
problem and now you're spending on money
to go in and fix it supporting grain
well so many people are suffering
because in every country in the world
no matter what else divides us
if parents cannot feed their children
nothing nothing else matters if parents
cannot feed their children
as we look to the Future
we're working with our partners to
update and create rules of the road for
new challenges we face in the 21st
century so just to be clear we're
talking about that it's not like the
green New Deal or or environmentally
minded legislation would in any way try
and be punitive towards companies that
Harvest or manufacture meat right he's
talking about 100 feet feed families
right right it's not like they would be
trying to artificially subsidize and
move us towards a diet that is primarily
plant-based right which by the requires
huge giant vast swaths of land
so he's making he's not making anything
cost prohibitive right because parents
need to feed their kids he's slashing
taxes and regulations and red tape
across the board so that we won't have
for example a meat shortage and I don't
have them as a sponsor uh here on the
show today but go to goodranchors.com
enter in the promo code Crowder because
you lock in that price there is a there
is a beef shortage that's coming down
the pike just so you know it's happening
resilient sustainable and shared
that's why the United States is
championed Global minimum tax
and we will work to see it implemented
so major corporations pay their fair
share everywhere everywhere according to
who it's also been the idea I agree on
anything economics for corporations
across the globe
and we're gonna also build a colony on
Mars tomorrow
but I would have believed that first I
think yeah I would have yeah
Pacific region that's free and open
Connected and prosperous secure and
resilient
together with Partners around the world
we're working to serve you secure
resilient support yeah he's a big fan of
Syracuse everyone
from orange or domination and I'm sure
that no country can use energy as a
weapon
and as Russia's War rolls Royals the
global economy oh boy we're also calling
on major Global creditors including let
me just examine that really quickly okay
that no country uses energy as a weapon
now presumably we're not talking about
like you know like atomic energy we know
what he's saying he's talking about
energy he's talking about resources okay
there's only one way in which any
country could use energy as a weapon
that's if other countries are dependent
on it right
it's not a weapon if you don't need
their energy the United States
right now could be not only entirely
energy independent right now if we
allowed it to happen and of course there
would need to be some time to build up
the infrastructure but we have to we
could also Supply more of the world with
energy just to be clear we don't need
Rush don't need Saudi Arabia we don't
need those agreements but we're not
allowed to
we're not allowed to the only way it's
able to be used as a weapon is what what
well if it's done so under the guise of
the globalist economy the
internationalism which you so fervently
support if we say hey you know what
we're a nationalist country we're going
to look out for our own interests guess
what
you just made the case for it no one can
use energy as a weapon against us or a
food shortage against us yeah by the way
it is entirely reasonable to use energy
as a weapon against the people who are
supporting your enemy I'm not agreeing
with Russia invading you no but I'm
saying if you're if you're on the side
of Russia and you're like ah well all
these countries that we supply energy to
they keep sending money in arms we'll
just turn the energy off well we can't
do that because Biden said that was
wrong they have nothing else to do you
saw their Soldier and didn't I mean we
did the exact same thing to Japan with
oil prior to them bombing Pearl Harbor
I'm not agreeing with them then we gave
them a whole bunch of energy in one shot
well
for years to come Josh Hartnett says a
little bit
it doesn't make any sense to me at all
and by the way if that is your he didn't
drop the bomb he was part of the the I
was busy making out with Faith Hill or
something you know what I mean no but if
that's your policy where energy can't be
used as a weapon like you said shouldn't
you be the most pro-energy independent
Administration that this country has
ever seen which means you would be
saying drill everywhere you can until we
get to a place where we have completely
renewable energy build every nuclear
power plant that you can possibly build
do every pipeline that every pipeline is
welcome as long as it's safe and meets
the standards of the industry like over
that [ __ ] you get a pipeline and you get
a pipeline cut that bam yeah you know
what I mean so well you're going to
Emerald Lagasse way but sure I did I did
I went a little different no here's the
thing and I know what you're going to
say and I'll just point you to a
references for premium returns actually
he opened up more federal land leases no
no he he did it you're talking about
again shut down more when you look at
the leases that were taking place under
Donald Trump and not only that we're not
talking about leases where that
currently exists but new ones and new
land is also something that's very
important so this idea they'll try and
say actually he's done more for energy
Independence than any president it's
complete and total [ __ ] I've done an
entire segment on it just want to cut
that off with past because I know a lot
of you who are new probably don't know
the [ __ ] that you've been spoon fed
we've already addressed it
that guy everything that guy said is
[ __ ] all right let's see is that
next day I know we got to get going but
Wayne committed to our one choice
just help prevent Conflict for four
decades
let's go to Mud Club and give give these
guys a little okay so yeah benefit there
well we'll we'll stream this live more
on mug club uh like I said Dave's going
to be back here next week he has a I
don't want a family member who has some
health issues so send them your comments
Your Love below prayers you can send
them to them on Instagram or on Twitter
uh like share any of that stuff it helps
the show it helps the algorithm because
he can't find us on YouTube right now
we're going to continue streaming this
we may play Photoshop or not I think we
should just keep dreaming this because
this guy because it's you know it's it's
he's an [ __ ] uh YouTube piss off
foreign